[Music]
i think that is it i mean there is i saw
a question when you sent me the email i
saw a question that flesh and blood will
not inherit the kingdom of god it was
from several weeks ago i'd like to
address that that's okay with you oh yes
let's do it let's do it let's pray
father in heaven as i try to answer this
question give me wisdom that you may be
glorified and your people enlightened in
jesus name we pray amen the
question was
how do you reconcile the fact that flesh
and blood cannot inherit the kingdom of
god and yet jesus christ was physical
when he rose flesh and blood will not
inherit the kingdom of god yes but flesh
and blood does not always mean sin it
can also mean corruptability in first
thessalonians 15th verses but this i say
that flesh and blood shall not inherit
the kingdom of god but the last part of
that verse explained nor does corruption
inherit corruption what paul is saying
when we come from the grave something
will happen we will change from flesh
and learn meaning corruptability
susceptible to death susceptible to
decomposition susceptible to decay that
is what flesh and blood means in in in
that context and he goes on to say
behold i show you a mystery we shall not
all
asleep but we shall be changed in a
moment in the twinkling of an eye and
the last trump for the trump shall sound
and the dead shall be raised
incorruptible and we shall be changed
for this corruptable must put on
incorruption corruptible means flesh and
blood in corruption means you're no
longer subject to death and so flesh and
blood shall not inherit the kingdom
simply means that
to enter his kingdom we must have the
body christ's heart now sin won't
inherit the kingdom either flesh and
blood may mean sin but if you read
philippians 3 20
for our conversation is in heaven for
whence also if you look for the savior
the lord jesus who shall change our vile
bodies that he might be fashioned like
unto his glorious body we have violent
glorious the word fire does not
necessarily mean sinful it means
corruptable because paul is addressing
the saints who will take us to heaven so
he says our vile bodies shall be changed
to his glorious body so vile flesh and
blood means susceptible to death and
decomposition
incorruptible is what we will have in
the new world so that's what fashion
blood means to not inherit the kingdom
of god but sin doesn't inherit it either
i rattle through that but i hope
somebody understood something
amen it gives me an opportunity to say
study the bible contextually don't just
speak a verse and say here's what the
verse says study the verses after the
verses before the chapter before the
chapter after the entire book what was
the the the intent of the author all of
that you've got to study to come to the
correct conclusion this is what the
bible says we do the bible this
injustice we do ellen white injustice by
not uh
interpreting her comprehensively